today on the matt wall show already the
clamoring has begun to accept thousands
of afghan refugees meanwhile our own
people thousands of them are still
trapped in afghanistan and the bible
administration is not guaranteeing that
they will all be rescued this is another
example of what an america last policy
looks like also a top vaccine official
in tennessee said that she was mailed a
dog muzzle as a threat from anti-vaxxers
you'll never guess who really sent it
well you probably already have guests
but still meanwhile new zealand goes
into full lockdown over one covid case
just one and australia has now
instructed its people that they must not
drink outside without a mask and the
biggest news of all of course is carrie
underwood sparking controversy by liking
one of my tweets this headline making
news has caused lots of distress to lots
of people and it's all quite hilarious
we'll talk about that today and more on
matt walsh
[Music]
[Applause]
before we get going here today uh i want
to
listen to a word from one of our
favorite sponsors here is charity mobile
and uh the reason we love charity mobile
so much is it's a great service and
great company but also it gives us an
opportunity to support a company that
doesn't hate our guts which is always
nice because you're forcing your money
into the hands of people who hate you
much of the time when you're out there
you know
buying anything really or taking
advantage of any service but here's a
chance to support a company that
actually supports you charity mobile is
the pro-life phone company and uh
they're they're probably a fun company
because five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro family
pro-life charity of your choice what
that means is that you're joining a
company that shares your beliefs and
won't cancel or censor you for them in
fact they're going to help spread those
beliefs and and encourage them and
support them in the culture which are so
important you're also getting excellent
coverage with nationwide service on
america's most reliable network uh
charity mobile makes it easy to switch
also you can keep your existing phone
number and you may even be able to keep
your existing phone as well but 5g
phones are also available so it's easy
to do you're it's a great company a
great service and you're helping to
build a culture of life in america
simply by paying your bill every month
you cannot beat it so switch to charity
mobile and support a company that causes
and causes that you care about call them
at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention the
offer code walsh
we began the show yesterday with a
spokesman for the state department
standing in front of the press and
bravely demanding that the taliban
become an inclusive and equitable
organization our government has been
unequivocal about this the the
bloodthirsty cave-dwelling goat herders
frozen in time since the year 750 must
immediately and without delay adopt the
value system of a 20 year old women's
studies major
last night ambassador linda thomas
greenfield appeared on cnn to again
drive this point home and they just
sound dumber and dumber every time they
do it so here's the latest listen
we are hearing from people in
afghanistan that they are getting
threats from the taliban and we have
expressed in no uncertain terms here at
the united nations through a very
strongly worded press statement from the
security council that we expect the
taliban to respect human rights
including the rights of women and girls
we have also indicated that they have to
be respectful of humanitarian law and
that we do not expect to see that
afghanistan will become a safe haven for
terrorists
a very strongly worded press statement
not just a strongly worded press
statement a very strongly worded press
statement the taliban must be shaking in
their birkenstocks i mean you can
imagine them fleeing for cover running
and screaming take cover a press
statement they issued a press statement
get down
hopefully there will not be a need to
use this kind of force again though as
the taliban has promised pinky promised
as i understand to behave themselves and
be very respectful of women and
minorities and all protected classes of
people the u.n for its part is ready to
take the taliban at its word here's this
from reuters they say the chief of field
operations of the un children's agency
expressed cautious optimism about
working with taliban officials following
their seizure of power in afghanistan
citing their early expressions of
support for girls education
quote we have ongoing discussions we are
quite optimistic based on those
discussions unicef's chief of field
operations afghanistan told a u.n
briefing adding that 11 out of 13 field
offices were currently operational we
have not a single issue with the taliban
in those field offices
well it's good that they're optimistic
the people clinging to the outside of a
c-17 to get out of the country did not
appear to be
quite as optimistic however and there is
reason to lend more credibility to their
assessment than to the un
uh one reason is just that the u.n is a
scourge on this earth and nothing they
say about anything is is true
but also
and here's a basic fact that seems to be
incomprehensible to so many people in
the west but we have to understand this
if you want to understand anything about
how the world works
you need to know this
members of the taliban
like so many non-western people
do not believe in women's rights in fact
they don't believe in rights at all
i know that seems shocking to people
these days how could you not believe in
rights well they don't
they have no concept of human rights
they have no language for it
things like humanitarian law and human
rights these are uniquely western
and uniquely modern
they are not universally recognized
truths but rather dogmas they're part of
a religious creed which is peculiar to
our age and our civilization as it turns
out history did not begin 10 years ago
and the earth does in fact expand beyond
our local boundaries
just because we have a certain way of
looking at things that doesn't mean that
everyone has always looked at it that
way either in the past or the present
now that's not to say that all beliefs
are valid and everyone's perspective is
true in its own way i'm not making a
pitch for relativism here but for
realism
i believe that we have god-given rights
understood a certain way though
even we don't really understand what we
mean when we talk about rights which is
why none of us can agree about what our
rights are or where they come from
yet i believe there is a truth here an
objective truth the point simply is that
in order to see this truth you need a
certain philosophical and religious
framework yes religious framework
which does not exist in that part of the
world
human rights are at root a christian
theological concept
that's what they are that's what they
will always be
so in order to get anyone to really
recognize and respect human rights
you first have to convince them to adopt
the entire framework upon which human
rights are based
but that's not a project that can be
accomplished in 20 years or double that
time or triple that time
and it's not a goal that our government
is capable of achieving in any length of
time because our government is now and
has been for a long while
run by people who also reject the human
rights framework
most of the people like those in the u.n
or the state department who demand that
the whole world respect human rights
they don't themselves respect human
rights and worse still
they can't articulate any reason why
anyone actually ought to respect them
nor can they explain what human rights
are or where they come from
the people proclaiming this gospel of
human rights have not read it don't
agree with it
don't like it
which is all the more reason to abandon
our colonial ambitions and return home
to rescue our nation from its own
collapse
now of course when i say return home i
mean everyone
all of the americans in afghanistan need
to be brought home which is a point that
the buy administration apparently thinks
is negotiable jen pasake when asked
about the americans trapped in
afghanistan and asked if she could
guarantee that all of these people would
would be able to to leave
well she she very noticeably did not
issue that guarantee here she is
can you
offer any guarantee to the americans and
afghan allies that if they remain there
past the end of the month u.s troops
will help them evacuate we'll pass the
end of the month
our focus right now is uh undoing the
work at hand and on the task at hand and
that is day by day getting as many
american citizens as many siv applicants
as many members of a vulnerable
population who are eligible to be
evacuated to the airport and out on
planes and we're going to do that in
expeditious fashion that is the focus of
the president of our secretary of
defense of our secretary of state uh and
everybody on our national security team
uh so that that is where we will keep
our efforts go ahead
so no guarantee in other words and the
government has been more explicit about
this elsewhere elsewhere according to
the atlantic an email was sent out to
americans stranded in afghanistan
telling them they should they should
make their own way to the airport
they're on their own for that part of
the trip like get yourself here that's
up to you
and during that process their safety
cannot be assured the email said quote
please be advised the united states
government cannot guarantee your
security as you make this trip
meanwhile as jen pasaki stipulated
the focus remains on not just evacuating
americans but also siv applicants
and vulnerable populations
there are ten thousand americans still
in afghanistan the government has gotten
hundreds of people out of the country so
far not nearly fast enough
and the vast majority of the people
evacuated are not american citizens
they're at the back of the line as it
stands right now based on the latest
report the non-american evacuees
outnumber the americans by like three to
one
it would be too generous to say that the
bite administration is uh you know
treating afghans and americans equally
in the evacuation process that would be
bad enough
it's more true to say
that they're prior they are prioritizing
non-americans
this was illustrated in stark detail
when the first plane took off from the
airport
we know what the outside of the plane
looked like looked like but
if you look at the inside check out the
inside of the plane
and what do you see when you look at
this picture
not only are there easily
10 times the number of men than women
and children
but every single one of these people
would appear to be afghans
the very first people we got out of the
country the first plane load our first
priority were afghans
i don't know
how else to describe this other than the
word diabolical we are leaving americans
to die
while carting afghan citizens out of the
country by the plane load
and now we have both republicans and
democrats solemnly insisting that our
first priority is to bring these foreign
citizens into our country in a hurry all
at once
there are almost 200 countries on this
planet okay
and for some reason it has to always
fall to us always to take in the
refugees
it's always our responsibility
the u.n has said that too well we just
you got to bring them in
what about everybody else
what about the rest of you guys what are
you doing
what about the surrounding muslim
countries
so these people can
you know go to a to a culture that is
familiar to them
why aren't you stepping up to the plate
and many of the people who insist that
you know we we need to bring in the
refugees
they also believe that america is a
racist oppressive dystopia not that
dissimilar from afghanistan under the
under under the taliban
so you would think that they would want
the refugees to go elsewhere for their
own sake
but then that would be to expect
intellectual consistency from these
people which is always
too much to ask
you know i don't see why it should be
our job our responsibility much less a
safe and prudent plan to accept an
unchecked flood of fighting age afghan
males
and who knows how many of whom are
taliban or at least sympathetic to the
taliban
that's that's not a safe plan to begin
with
and
you know if you if you trust the
government to sift through these people
and to and to go through the vetting
process
and to do it well
if you trust them then you just haven't
been paying attention at all
but at any rate we shouldn't even be
having that conversation until all of
the americans are home
not one afghan should be on an american
transport leaving the country until
every single american has been safely
retrieved
and the biden administration if it gave
the slightest dam about its own people
would be on tv every hour of the day
assuring us that they will move heaven
and earth they will do whatever needs to
be done they will drop whatever bombs
have to be dropped they will kill
whoever they need to kill
in order to get our people out
that's what they would be saying
they would be saying we're gonna get our
people out anyone who stops us we will
kill them we will destroy them
instead they yawn and say yeah well you
know we'll get a few of them out maybe
if they manage to survive the trip to
the airport because by the way we shut
down our air force base before we
started the evacuation process great
plan there
we have to understand that what we are
witnessing now is not mere incompetence
this is rather the inevitable result of
an american government
that doesn't put america first and that
phrase america first should not be a
partisan slogan or a slogan at all
it shouldn't even need to be said
obviously we should put our own people
first we're americans they're our people
just as you shouldn't ever need to say
or clarify that you put your own family
above your neighbor's family
it should be
obvious and your actions should never
give cause anyone to question whether
you have that value system or not
yet as far as america first we do need
to say it now because our country is run
by people who don't understand the world
they're operating within
don't care about the country they're in
charge of
and don't even like the people they lead
incompetent no they're they're doing
exactly what they mean to do exactly how
they mean to do it
and that's the problem
now let's get to our five headlines
if you use a helix mattress like i do
and then hopefully you do then you know
the experience of if you're staying at
someone else's house you're traveling
you're at a hotel where they don't have
a helix mattress that is all that can
always be a little bit traumatizing to
have that experience because no other
mattress lives up to the helix mattress
uh that's that's the downside is that
you you know you
you kind of see what you're missing when
you go somewhere else but when you're at
your home on that mattress you cannot
beat it look helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you it works every time so if you like a
mattress that's really soft or firm
whether you sleep on your side or your
back wherever you sleep whatever
whatever your sleeping position is what
kind of whatever kind of mattress you
like helix sleep has the perfect
mattress and it takes just a couple of
minutes to fill out this quiz so you
might as well go give it a shot go to
helixsleep.com walsh take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life
guaranteed they have a 10-year warranty
and you get that you get to try it out
for 100 nights
risk-free if you don't like it for some
reason you can send it back risk-free
but i guarantee you will like it right
now helix is offering up to 200 off and
free pillows with all mattress orders
for our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash wall street's helix sleep.com
welsh for up to 200 off your mattress
order
um all right by the way a quick update
on this
uh for for the people that have been
asking
um as you know this um
psychological warfare that has been is
being waged on me
by uh members of my family to try to
convince me to get a dog and
i did find myself this just this past
weekend
at a uh at an animal shelter
looking at dogs
and
which which again is is not a smart move
but i was there we were looking at the
dogs and you have to understand like
first we had my wife and my kids a
couple weeks ago
they were trying to convince me to to
that we should adopt this little poodle
chihuahua mangy looking thing
totally useless dog
and then we're at the animal shelter um
looking at some of the dogs and now
they're trying to convince me to adopt a
an enormous four-year-old
rottweiler
and bring that into the house
now what you have to understand now i'm
not i'm not an expert on these issues at
all
uh but
you know added there's there's a reason
why a dog is at an animal shelter and if
it's a rottweiler at an animal shelter
there's probably a reason why it was
there now if you look on the you know in
all the cages and it says like how did
this dog end up in the animal shelter
and every single one of them says oh it
was a stray that just wandered in they
were all strays yeah i'm sure they were
right
it's a lot of owners bringing their dogs
in and saying uh yeah this is a stray
it's not mine because they don't want to
admit what they're doing
so
i i i get the feeling that my wife and
kids when it comes to the dog search are
are being are motivated primarily by
emotions here
and their guiding principle is what is
what's the cutest let's just bring the
cutest thing even if it's useless or it
could be a
the snarling rabbit death machine
doesn't matter as long as it's cute
what i'm up against
all right so here's a fun story michelle
fiskus was one of the top vaccine
officials here in tennessee she was
fired justifiably after distributing a
memo encouraging medical professionals
to vaccinate children
without their parents consent or excuse
me let me clarify
rather she she shared information about
how they could do that not that she was
suggesting it
all she was saying she she distributed
the memo
saying hey i
i'm just saying you could vaccinate kids
without their parents look outside i'm
not encouraging you but
by the way here's the law and by the way
you could do that
hint wink wink and in the middle of that
backlash
um
because this
this creep
was trying to supersede the authority of
parents
encouraging people to inject these
substances into kids without parents
even knowing in the middle of that
backlash before leaving her position she
claimed to have received a dog muzzle in
the mail as a threat of some kind from
presumably an anti-vaxxer probably a
trump trump supporter one of those
dangerous people you know here she is on
cnn this was a few weeks ago talking
about this uh terrible threat that she
received let's watch this
i i understand so just last week before
you were fired you received a disturbing
amazon package at your office
what was in it and what did you think
when you received it
hi anderson thank you so much for having
me um yes the the week before i was
terminated from the department of health
i received a package that contained a
dog muzzle um and
at first i thought that was a joke and
contacted a few friends and then when no
one claimed it realized that that was
something that was sent to me as some
kind of a message i suppose i understand
i think it was your husband who said or
you said something to your husband that
he recounted what was it you said
i said
that that they obviously didn't know me
because they sent me a size three which
is for beagles and i'm obviously a pit
bull which requires a size six
really clever
she's a pit bull all right
um question
again not being an expert on dogs are
pit bulls known for lying are they are
they a particularly deceptive breed of
dog maybe they are
because if so she's a pit bull because
as it turns out this was all shockingly
a lie now we have this from the daily
wire it says an investigation revealed
the muzzle was actually purchased on
fiskus's own credit card though she
still denies that she sent the muzzle to
herself as some sort of hate hoax
according to axios an investigation from
the tennessee department of safety and
homeland security revealed that the
amazon package containing the dog muzzle
was traced back to a credit card in
fiskus's name
so no problem here it's a former
government official in charge of the
vaccines in the state
mailing a dog muzzle to herself
and so
stupid
here's the thing that
where you want to say
like it's almost hard to believe you
almost want to give her the benefit of
the doubt because you say would she
really be so dumb
as to perpetrate this hoax in the first
place but then to put it on her own
credit card
how stupid do you have to be
like why wouldn't you go at least if
you're gonna do this
go to a petsmart or something buy the
thing in cash
and then mail it to yourself at a you
know a mailbox somewhere in a shopping
center
a little bit harder to trace if you're
gonna do this whole thing then i mean
really go for it
instead she just went on amazon with her
own credit card sent it to herself
knowing it would be investigated and
they could easily obtain this
information
so you want to give it give her the
benefit out but of course you can't
because
um
these hate hoe hoaxers as we have
learned time and time again really are
this stupid or maybe not so stupid at
all
maybe she realized
that it didn't matter whether it was
true or not
all that matters is the initial headline
as we have also learned time and time
again with these hoaxes
all you got to do is get the get the
initial headline
you become a victim you get all that
attention
which you can profit off of and
capitalize on
if a few weeks later or even a few days
later if it turns out the whole thing
was made up no
it's
all of the people who are willing to
accept you as a martyr they don't care
the truth doesn't mean anything to them
so it might not be so stupid after all
she realizes that the people this is
meant to appeal to for them the truth is
totally irrelevant so
who cares
and that's exactly how it has uh has
turned out
um and she's still denying it she say i
didn't set it to myself i guess the the
person who sent the dog muzzle first
stole her credit card
maybe stole it from her purse
bought the dog muzzle mail to her and
then snuck into her house the middle
night and put the put the credit card
back in her purse you never know could
have happened
all right next we have
jack jenkins religious news service
reporter
on twitter has this he says diocese of
lexington kentucky mandates covet 19
vaccines for staff as a condition of
employment bishop john stowe
of the diocese say that says there is no
religious exemption for catholics to
being vaccinated and pope francis
has repeatedly called this a moral
obligation
uh yeah it's a moral obligation to get
vaccinated he says
which is obviously nonsense
but what makes this all the more
frustrating
and irritating
is that this language of moral
obligation
this is exactly the kind of language
that many of us in the catholic church
many of the laity have been calling on
bishops to use for decades
by and large with some exceptions
the leadership
in the catholic church in america anyway
and beyond america unfortunately has
given up the language of moral
obligation they don't talk about it
anymore anymore
um
and they certainly don't put their foot
down about anything
taking a bold stand drawing a line and
saying you cannot cross this line
[Music]
here's what it means to be a catholic
here are your moral obligations here are
your responsibilities
for decades they've abandoned this
language they don't want to talk about
it and now finally these bishops
these weak whimpering bishops
with no spine no courage to stand up
against any evil at all
to call out any sin
now they have finally found an evil and
a sin and uh
a villain that they're willing to call
out and that would be the unvaccinated
they finally discovered these people a
moral obligation
and it is the obligation to get
vaccinated just as the government tells
you to that's the moral obligation
i mean the moral obligation to
uh
you know care for your own children
rather than killing them in the womb
a lot of these bishops they don't even
talk about that they don't want to talk
about that
the moral obligation to chastity
they don't talk about that
any virtue they're not going to discuss
that
because that would be otherwising right
that would be
that would turn people off that would
upset people
that's not welcoming
you know the focus in the church has
been on let's welcome in let's throw
open the doors and welcome everyone even
if they're not catholic and have no
interest in being catholic whatsoever
they're opposed to the catholic faith
and everything we stand for let's
welcome them in let's put them in
positions of leadership even
that doesn't matter let's have priests
who don't even believe any of this stuff
doesn't make a difference
now they have finally now after decades
of this
and the church in in the midst of a
full-scale collapse in this country and
across the west because of this now they
have finally
closed the doors a little bit
and said okay we're not going to be
welcoming of everyone who aren't we
going to welcome the unvaccinated
and also this from cnn um
says new zealand's prime minister
jacinda ardern has announced a
nationwide lockdown after the country
confirmed well wait to that in a second
let's listen first to jacinda ardern and
then we'll talk about what prompted this
but
here is jacinda prime minister
announcing this lockdown and uh
instructing her citizens on how they are
to behave from here from henceforth
here she is
stay local and do not congregate don't
talk to your neighbours
please keep to your bubbles it comes
down again to those very simple
principles
we know from overseas
cases of the delta variant that it can
be spread by people simply walking past
one another so keep those movements
outside to the bare minimum
wear a mask and make sure you keep up
that physical distancing
they're very concerned we heard this
from the health official in australia
last week don't talk don't talk to
anybody
don't even pass by anyone on the street
she claims that we know that the delta
varia can be spread by walking past
someone on the street really we know
that how do we know that where's that
data
show me any data at all to support that
where has it been proven that you can
spread covet to another person by
walking past them
so we're talking about
one or two seconds
of being within the general vicinity of
another human being that's enough to
infect them really
even if they're vaccinated still
where's the data on that well there's
there's no data on that at all that is
she made that up
she's standing in front of her her
people making things up
doesn't matter nobody's going to call
her on it
and why are they going into this this is
a full national lockdown stay in your
homes don't talk to anyone don't even
pass by someone on the street and why is
that because of
one case
one case
in the whole country one dude in new
zealand
has covered
no reason to think it's even a severe
case but he has it and now the entire
country shuts down
do you know how many deaths
new zealand has had from kovid this year
zero
the white supremacist symbol zero
um they have had zero deaths since i
believe last spring
and since kova began they have less than
30 deaths
in a year and a half
and now one case and they shut down the
whole country
and as i always say with this the the
the the really disturbing thing
is how many people will look at this and
say that makes sense to me
it does not shock me or surprise me that
a person
in charge of a country a politician
would want to exercise this kind of
power if she can get away with it the
thing that is kind of shocking and very
upsetting is that she can get away with
it
in fact just talking about this and
seeing some of the social media reaction
there are a lot of people in this
country saying let's she's setting an
example from the world for the world why
can't we do this
it's obviously working they say
that's what we're told is that is that
this is this is a good idea to shut down
the entire country for one case
of a disease that has been that has
hardly been deadly at all in your
country
hardly anyone has died of covid in in
new zealand this entire time
uh but they say it's working so let's do
it
well here's the problem with that first
of all
there isn't a lot of reason to think
that it's working in the first place
this is new zealand it's one of the most
isolated populated places on earth
in terms of populated land masses it's
hard it's it's harder it's hard to get
more isolated than new zealand
okay they're an island nation
their closest neighbor
um which you have to travel across an
ocean to get to
uh is australia and their closest
neighbor to the south is antarctica okay
their closest neighbor to the south is a
barren frozen wasteland
so there are a lot of advantages there
already
they don't get a ton of tourism to begin
with
uh they're certain it's certainly not
like us
where we are an international hub of
people coming and going we've got
refugees coming in we got this and that
we've got people flooding across the
southern border
i'd say new zealand doesn't have anyone
coming across the southern border unless
it's penguins
from antarctica
uh so there's no reason to think
that any of the measures they're they're
putting in place have made all that much
of a difference
for all of those reasons their isolation
they were never going to get hit by this
very hard in the first place but anyway
let's pretend for a second that it is
working
well okay
yeah
big shocker if you if you know if you
shut down your entire country
because of one case of an illness that's
not all that deadly yeah the illness
probably won't spread
yes it works in that sense
but
um
if you also care about things like
having a functioning society
living an actual life
being a functioning human being
if that matters to you then no this
doesn't work
if the only thing that matters
is stopping covid and it is literally
the only consideration
is stopping people from getting covered
if the number one priority
and the only priority is stopping covet
then sure it works
but if you care about literally anything
else
then no this solution does not work
uh we also have to play this here's a
guy in australia i'm not even sure who
this guy is but uh some somewhat in a
position of leadership oh
the victoria premier daniel andrews is
who it is
and uh here he is uh
explaining some more of the coveted
measures and telling you some more
things that you cannot do in australia
let's listen
there will be
no removal of masks to consume alcohol
outdoors
so you will no longer be able to remove
your mask to drink a cocktail
at a pop-up beer garden on a footpath
as part of a pub crawl
you can't you you
you cannot take off your mask to drink
outside
but notice he doesn't say you can't
drink outside
which would be absurd enough on its own
obviously
what he's saying is there will be no
removing of masks to drink
outside which would clearly seem to
imply that
you could still drink outside to keep
your mask on
i guess what he's saying is uh the
safest thing if you gotta drink outside
no we certainly are not gonna be
drinking inside uh but if you're gonna
be drinking outside if you want to drink
it all if you want to consume any
liquids at all the safest thing is to
water board yourself with your beer and
your mask
throw your head back and dump the beer
onto your mask
and hope you don't suffocate in the
process
many many many a taliban have been
through that process themselves
you know and many of them survived
and now they're running afghanistan so
who knows maybe you will too one day
okay let's uh i also want to hit this
from the daily wire it says naomi
osaka's return to taking questions in a
press conference setting did not go well
she was the tennis star
who uh
dropped out of the french open you may
recall a few months ago
because she didn't want to take any
questions from the press
uh because it hurts her mental health
and she doesn't like having asked answer
questions she doesn't like experiencing
you know talking to anyone who doubts
her or questions her in any way
it's very traumatizing to her
and
she
finally returned to answering some
questions i'm going to skip ahead here
because there was an interaction
between her and a reporter
and after that interaction osaka starts
crying
and eventually leaves the press
conference
and then this from the daily wire they
say after the press conference osaka's
agent stuart duigid
lashed out at the cincinnati enquirer
reporter calling his behavior appalling
ben rothenberg said quote
um
or rather do good said to uh to a
reporter named ben martha
rothenberg the bully at the cincinnati
enquirer is the epitome of why player
media relations are so fraught right now
everyone on that zoom will agree that
his tone was all wrong and his sole
purpose was to intimidate really
appalling behavior
okay so
that's the context it was bullying it
was intimidating it was horrible
now let's play the video of that
interaction with this bullying
intimidating reporter and you tell me if
if this seems intimidating to you let's
listen
um you're not crazy about dealing with
with with us
especially in this format
yet you have a lot of outside interests
that are served by having a media
platform i guess my question is
how do you balance the two and also do
you have anything you'd like to share
with us about what you did say to simone
biles
um when you say i'm not crazy about
dealing you with you guys what does that
refer to
well you've said it you don't especially
like the press conference format
yet that seems to be the the obviously
the most widely used means of
communicating to the media and through
the media to the public
that's interesting um
i would say the occasion like when
to do the press conference is what i
feel is the most difficult
but
hmm
hopefully it's okay if i ask a couple of
tennis questions um the first one is
just uh uh how the training has been and
how your preparation has been for the
for the summer hard court swing
okay so you see at the end there if
you're especially if you're only
listening to this you don't have the the
visual cues this has to be very
confusing i'm sure you're listening to
that and waiting like when what are you
talking what
when when does the the bullying reporter
show up well that was it well you just
heard there the guy asking the question
is was bullying and then at the end
osaka is kind of stumped by the question
can barely even speak
and then she starts crying wiping away
tears and she covers her face with her
uh with the brim of her ball cap
and eventually ends up leaving the press
conference she's so distraught
and then sends her agent out
sicks her agent on this guy calling him
a bully all he did was
ask a question that's all there was
there was nothing
remotely contentious about it or hostile
even if there was
you're a grown-ass woman deal with
it okay you're a professional athlete
even if someone comes at you with a
little bit of hostility you should be
able to handle that but there's no
hostility it was a very fair very basic
question
and she could barely speak in response
to it and then starts crying
this is
and and yet again
the reaction has
mostly been
on to her defense
and the irony here is is that people say
well this is all about mental health and
everything
um
no the message to asaka should be this
is mental illness like you have serious
problems and i don't i don't say that
to to insult you
but if you as a grown person as a grown
adult
cannot handle
the most basic kind of question
you are reduced to tears
at being questioned at all
at being forced to justify your behavior
to any extent at all if that reduces you
to tears as an adult then you've got
serious issues
if if my own kids
you know if one of my eight-year-olds
couldn't handle any line of questioning
at all
um without without
you know collapsing into tears i would
think that they've got some serious
problems
and they're only eight
you'd say well a little bit of this is
the fact that they're eight years old
but
they should have still have more
maturity at this age than that
you're an adult
you've got serious mental problems
serious
that should be the message anyone really
concerned about naomi osaka and her
mental health the message should be
listen lady you got serious mental
problems here
and uh you need to get into some some
kind of counseling
because this is unreasonable your
response here is totally unreasonable
and frankly insane
instead they affirm it and justify it
and say this is a completely reasonable
way to respond as an adult
which only means and this is the common
theme
that she will not get help for her
mental health problems
because she is being affirmed
in her insane behavior
where else have we seen that in the
culture
all right moving on now to reading the
comments this is from rogue leader says
how can the taliban include women when
the state department can't even define
women
yet anot another contradiction you're
exactly right
and yet another reason why our state
department and our government is not
equipped
you know to
be spreading this kind of message abroad
another comment says wait there's going
to be a panel of judges for the sbg song
shouldn't there be only be one judge our
our well-loved sbg daddy walsh
well to be clear yeah there is going to
be a panel of judges and american idol
style judging will go on of the sweet
baby gang anthem the only reason the
other judges will be there is just
because it'll make them very
uncomfortable
and that will be funny
the fact that anyone else here at the
daily wire is going to be roped into
this completely ridiculous thing that
makes no sense at all that's that's why
they're there
um josh says all i got from this episode
was matt misgendered lizzo and just
glossed over it i'm so morally outraged
and i apologize for that josh and you're
exactly right very rare that i apologize
but you're right
i did assume her gender and i and and uh
you you held me to account for that and
you did the right thing
but you're still banned from the show
zach says we know matt isn't a white
supremacist because he hates all races
and people equally well thank you zack
that's my point um
another comment says matt walsh and ben
shapiro have opposing views on
afghanistan michael knowles too that's
one of the nice things about the daily
wire they can respectfully disagree
you'll never see opposing views on
mainstream media outlets cnn will have
three people on who are all in agreement
yeah that's why it's funny to me when i
i hear the accusation from people
anytime i express my views on anything
there's always going to be someone
saying someone in the peanut gallery
saying oh you're what did ben shapiro
pay you to say that
but ben shapiro told you to say that
didn't he
and in a way yeah he does pay me to say
the things i say because uh he's
you know he's signing the checks but
uh
we we actually disagree
and will disagree publicly on on
issues like this
and you're not going to find that in
very many other outlets
and that's because you know what
it shouldn't be shocking at all oh my
gosh matt walsh ben shapiro disagree
yeah we're both human beings with our
own brains and we form our own opinions
on things
that shouldn't be surprising that should
be the norm
in any organization any media outlet
where you have people employed there and
their job is to give their opinions
there should be there should be a wide
range of opinions there should be a lot
of disagreement
because these are not siamese twins
joined at the brain
and uh and it's it's that's not a
problem
you disagree with someone it's not
offensive it doesn't hurt my feelings
if ben shapiro disagrees with me doesn't
hurt my feelings i think i could speak
for him
and say it doesn't hurt his opinions or
hit hurt his feelings if i disagree with
him
it's it's okay it's fine
in fact it's good it's interesting
okay this is from eric says matt i loved
your school board speech and wish that i
could do something similar to my local
school board the problem is that i'm
terrified of public speaking and really
bad at it do you have any tips how did
you become so polished as a public
speaker um
well
okay a couple of tips none of this is
going to blow your mind but
first of all as far as nerves go when
you're getting up there to speak i hear
this from people a lot that you know
they want to be able to
give a speech or speak in front of
public but they get so nervous
um
i think it might help you to realize
that before you get up in front of any
audience
to deliver a speech
to realize that almost everyone on earth
is terrible at public speaking
almost everyone so there's no reason to
be too afraid
you know most of the people in the
audience are bad at it too
and the ones who are good at it won't
judge you for being bad at it because
they know that most people are bad at it
i mean just think about all of the
speeches you've heard in your life all
of the public addresses you've heard
whether a president on tv or a
politician or
you know a sermon at church
you know at a fundraising banquet at
school i mean anywhere all the different
times you've heard someone addressing a
public audience um
how many of the
of those speeches and addresses were
remotely interesting or compelling
very very few could probably count on
one hand the number of that were good
the rest of them were you know kind of
bad so it's a normal thing nothing to be
worried about the bar is really low
and you'll and
i think there's some comfort to be found
in that
and then as far as giving a good speech
the only two two things i would say is
uh first of all
you want to write it
write the speech
like you would say it
that's my method anyway i don't know
this is what they would tell you in
public speaking school
but that's what i think you should do is
certainly you don't want to write it
like a book report and that's what a lot
of it's what a lot of people do they
they write speeches like they're giving
a book report in fourth grade and they
get up there and they say today i'm
going to give a speech about yada yada
the dictionary defines yada yada as
no imagine yourself you're passionate
about this issue
and you're just you're having a
conversation with somebody one on one
what are the kinds of things you would
say how would you address it what sort
of tones would you use and try to
emulate that and you kind of that's why
when i write a speech i write it very
quickly
and then i go back and i kind of juice
it up a little bit and add in some more
descriptive language and that kind of
thing but my first pass the basic
framing of the speech will be very quick
because i want it to be sort of stream
of consciousness this is how i would
sound if i was saying it without a
script
then you go back around
and then the second thing is of course
to practice
um
and the point of practicing is not
memorizing the speech by the way
i think memorizing a speech is a waste
of time and memorized speeches often end
up sounding more like you're reading
them than if you just read them
so i never memorize a speech it's just a
matter of getting used to using the
words and all of that
you just heard us talking about the
sweet baby gang anthem if you don't know
what the sweet baby gang is then you're
outside of the gang and we're not going
to explain it to you but if you don't
know about the anthem challenge i will
tell you a little bit about that the
sweet baby gang is in need of a sweet
baby anthem and the daily wire is
opening up for submissions so i'm
looking for an original song that
embodies exactly what the sweet baby
gang is whatever that whatever that is
exactly all submissions should be in the
form of a youtube video all you need is
the link
and um you want to submit it to
dailywire.com
sbg
these videos are going to be these songs
are going to be judged in american idol
style sort of competition with me and
some of the other daily wire hosts who
are going to be subjected to this and
that is going to be so great i'm excited
for that submissions end on august 25th
so you only had a few days to take
advantage of this and get your
submissions in okay you will go down in
history
much like francis scott key
um you will go down in history for the
sweet baby gang anthem and this is an
anthem that i'll tell you one thing for
short nobody is going to kneel while it
is playing i will make sure of that so
go to dailywire.com sbg right now also
the morning wire we've been telling you
about that because you deserve to wake
up to the facts every morning which is
why we started our newest podcast
morning wire which has been topping the
apple and spotify charts since its
recent release it's the only daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to get this out to
more people so
go and subscribe tell your friends tell
your neighbors tell your loved ones and
also tell them about this candace is one
of the loudest voices in the fight for
the culture and if you're lucky you
might just get to hear that voice in
person if you sign up now as a daily
wire member with code vip you'll get 25
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two you and a guest to
the the daily wire studios to see
candace live you get to meet her you'll
see the show
it'll be a great time get 25 off a new
daily wire membership at dailywire.com
subscribe today and use code vip for
your chance to win now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
you've probably noticed
that there is not much going on in the
world these days certainly no major
crises either at home or abroad which
ought to attract our attention the earth
is a serene utopian garden of eden no
significant problems to be solved at all
and this explains why thousands and
thousands of people had both the time
and energy to become deeply outraged
yesterday over carrie underwood
liking a tweet
the country superstar was trending on
twitter and still might be actually and
the mob was all riled up because she had
apparently at some point in the last few
days
made the unconscionable decision to hit
the little heart button in reaction to a
tweet from a conservative commentator
who was criticizing mass mandates for
children and worst of all perhaps
is that the conservative commentator
was yours truly
it was my speech to the school board
that under underwood was expressing her
approval of and i feel quite guilty as
though i'm responsible for all of this
controversy or at least i would feel
guilty if it wasn't so damned hilarious
so perusing some of the outraged
comments you find lots of people
claiming to have been betrayed by the
twitter-like
i can't imagine what it must be like to
feel betrayed by a pop star
liking something on twitter and that's
mostly because i'm not mentally ill so i
don't know what that would feel like
many others accused underwood of being a
maga extremist and an anti-vaxxer even
though my video made no mention of
vaccines much less donald trump
and i saw at least one comment from
somebody implying
that they might kill themselves because
carrie underwood liked my video
totally normal and rational response
another person tweeted tweeted this they
said quote
absolutely gutted by the carrie
underwood news i used to wear a bracket
that said what would carrie underwood do
to remind me to always do the right
thing i can't believe such a kind caring
person would be against wearing a mask
to save lives my heart is broken
yes it's quite tragic his heart is
broken
his brain was obviously broken years ago
he's running out of internal organs this
is a this is a problem
and many comments were just like this
people utterly devastated to discover
that their favorite singer has at least
one viewpoint that differs from their
own
this is a reality that many people today
especially those on the left
cannot handle
and needless to say however not one
outraged person attempted to explain why
the bad speech from the scary
conservative was wrong
none of them bothered to defend their
assumption that my anti-mask views and
now presumably carry underwood's are
incorrect
there's no need to defend it all they
have is their emotions and that's all
they need
next the media got on to the case
articles were published in rapid
succession like this from yahoo headline
carrie underwood blasted for liking
anti-mask tweets and the toronto sun
carrie underwood slammed by fans for
liking anti-mask post
and radar online carrie underwood facing
backlash after liking tweets supporting
right-wing commentators anti-mask speech
calling school mandate child abuse
and the daily mail kelly carrie
underwood faces backlash from fans after
liking anti-mask tweet made by a
conservative commentator
perez hilton posted to instagram
explaining uh that the main controversy
in his opinion
is not underwood liking the tweet but
rather who made the original tweet he
then prompted his followers to swipe up
for the details about me
now originally i didn't swipe up for the
details because i figured i already know
everything i need to know about myself
but later it occurred to me that perez
hilton
wise sage that he is may have crucial
context about me that i myself am not
aware of so i went back and i swiped and
here's what i found
um
quote the video saw walsh making a slew
of blatantly false statements at a
nashville school board meeting claiming
claiming that masking students was child
abuse pushed by adults experiencing
munchausen syndrome by proxy and that
kova 19 poses almost no threat to our
kids at all which is just plain bull the
delta variant has actually led to a
spike in child hospitalizations
carrie has not denounced walsh or even
commented on the uproar that her like
has caused while she's previously voiced
support for progressive issues like gay
marriage in the past the songstress said
that she likes to stay far away out of
politics at least in the public because
nobody wins
well that's all very disappointing and i
was hoping for some real dirt on myself
instead once again we have someone
claiming that my claims are wrong while
providing no evidence at all to actually
debunk my claims
the bit about a spike in child
hospitalizations links to an article in
the new york times
and that article says right at the top
because this is this is something that i
do kind of a radical thing
where when someone links to something
claiming that the link provides evidence
for whatever
statement they're making
i will actually click on the link
and read it
and i did that here and what i found is
a new york times article that says in
italics right at the top in the
subheading i quote
it is not yet clear whether the delta
variant causes more severe disease in
children
translation
all of the data shows that covet is not
a serious threat to children and there
is no data right now at all to suggest
otherwise
but maybe there will be one day
in the future the media hopes
but back to the twitter like which again
is the most important issue here
and also the most important issue on
earth
as we know the final step in any
controversy of this type is the fact
check
and dutifully the media fact checkers
left into action newsweek published this
that says fact check did carrie
underwood's twitter account like like an
anti-mask mandate video
now this is something that you'd think
you could check in four seconds by going
to her account and looking
but jacob jarvis at newsweek somehow
managed to ring an entire lengthy
article out of this subject presumably
describing his entire investigative
process
it was a bold and daring journey no
doubt he was like indiana jones hacking
through the jungle battling nazis
navigating through ancient temples
running from boulders all to find out
whether carrie underwood liked my tweet
and it turns out yes she did the legends
of old are true
as for the identity of the dastardly
villain who posted the original tweet
jarvis discovered this he wrote quote
walsh has more than 620 000 twitter
followers and describes himself as a
theocratic fascist philanthropist and
beekeeping influencer on his profile
it's true i do
though i've also added style icon to my
profile a fact which did not make it
into this newsweek article newsweek has
delegitimized and erased my identity as
a fashion guru and for that i can't
forgive them but jarvis goes on quoting
me he writes quote in another tweet
walsh said quote all of you pathetic
dummies having a hissy fit are driving
thousands of views to my video that
you're mad about so yeah it's great
now wait a minute
that doesn't sound like something i
would say does it
well i guess it does
and it does also sound kind of rude when
you reprint it in an article like that
and you might argue that grown adults
reduce to tears because a pop star has
one opinion they disagree with certainly
deserve a rude and insulting response
like that
these are indeed pathetic dummies and
they probably haven't been called
pathetic dummies enough in their lives
it's important for them to know that
they're pathetic dummy so that perhaps
one day they might have a chance of
becoming something other than a pathetic
dummy you might argue that but you might
see it from the other side too
in fact
the more that i've reflected on this
issue
the more that i've
come to see really that
the outrage mob is right
i am
an extremist a radical frankly a
scoundrel
i'm a dangerous man and my opinions are
dangerous and my tweets are a hazard to
your health
who knows how many people i've killed
with my tweets and my statements and my
opinions the streets are
riddled with the bodies of my victims
people who were walking along looked at
their phone encountered one of my
opinions by accident dropped dead on the
spot it's happened more times
than i can count carrie underwood should
know better than to agree with anything
that i say much less to publicly agree
her lack of judgment in being at all
associated with me even indirectly is
appalling
i'm the most appalled and the most
offended because i know better than
anyone what a horrible monster i am
look if you're offended by my opinions
imagine how i must feel
i'm the one who has to think them
they're in my head i've got to live with
this every day
and if you hate the opinions i say out
loud you cannot fathom the opinions i
don't say out loud
admittedly i say almost all of them out
loud but still
the point is i am just as traumatized as
everyone else
and even more so
i consider myself to be in many ways the
primary victim
carrie underwood's behavior is repugnant
i have never been more disappointed
and that is why in the end
the more that i've thought about this
i have to join with the mob and saying
to carrie underwood you madam
are canceled
you should know better
disappointing
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everybody godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show president
biden tells americans in afghanistan
they're supposed to rely on the mercy of
the taliban america's enemies accelerate
their aggressive behavior and the hard
left signals that conservatives are the
real taliban that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen